calling all Gundam and Becca fans this
is an opportunity you wouldn't want to
miss we're here at Ocean Park Hong Kong
to check out the 50th Anniversary
exhibition of okawara kunio the father
of Gundam celebrating 50 years of his
work from the classic yataman and king
of Braves kaukaika to the Mobile Suit
Gundam series there's an extensive
collection of okarawasan's art and
documents here as well as hand-drawn
artwork that are being displayed in Hong
Kong for the first time keep an eye out
and you might even spot his signatures
on the walls we also took pictures with
these giant scoop Dogg voters and the
zaku and the strike Freedom Gundam which
all look really Majestic and don't
forget to check out the merchandise and
bring some cool swag home including the
50th Anniversary exhibition version of
the rx78 II to mention the very very
limited edition tourbillon watches that
you can pre-order right here there are
plenty of other attractions in Ocean
Park Hong Kong so we recommend you to
check it out